Let's walk through this code--so, first we set n is equal to the length
of the n by an adjacency matrix that we took as input
and we set assignment to be n(none), so a list of n(none)
and we initialize the cover to be the empty list since we haven't actually set a cover yet,
and we set valid off as false so that we can start this wild loop going
While valid is false, we first check to find the vertex with the most uncovered edges
So, we start with the first vertex and set candidate index to zero
and the number of uncovered neighbors that it has to zero.
Now, for every vertex in the graph, we check if it has already been assigned.
And if so, then already covers all adjacent edges.
If not, then we first set the sum of uncovered edges to be zero
and then again for every vertex in the graph, we check if there is an edge between the two vertices
represented by I and J and if J has been assigned.
If it hasn't been assigned, then we increment the sum of the uncovered edges
since there is now an edge that is not covered by either I or J,
and we loop through all of the other vertices to check if there is an edge between I and J.
Now, if the sum of the uncovered edges that we just counted up
is greater than the maximum uncovered neighbors
then we have a new candidate index for which vertex we should next add to the cover
and then we set the max uncovered neighbors to be sum uncovered, which we just calculated
and then we keep looping through this for every vertex until we find the max uncovered
So, we figured out which vertex we should next add to the cover.
Now, if we didn't find any uncovered neighbors, if max uncovered neighbors is zero
then we see that this is valid vertex cover.
We set valid to true and that means we'll fall out of this wild loop and continue on,
otherwise, we append this index to the current cover
and we set the assignment of this vertex to be one
and then we continue on finding the vertex with the next smallest number of uncovered adjacent edges.
Once, we eventually fall through that is once we eventually hit valid equal true here
and fall out of this wild loop, we go down here and calculate the size of the cover and return
So, size equal zero and then for every vertex in the graph,
we check if it is currently in the assignment.
And if so, we increment size and then we return size uncover.